الصدفه الخارقه للطبيعه قد تجعلك تلتقي
يوما ما بشبيهك ربما عند السفر او في
الطائره او حتى عند الذهاب الى التسوق قد
يختار البعض ان يجدوا
اشباهم عبر تطبيقات خاصه تمكنهم من العثور
على اشخاص يتمتعون بصفات شكليه
تشابههم
الدكتور منال الباحث في معهد جوزيف كاريرز
في برشلونه وجد ان الاشخاص المتشابهين
وفقا لبرنامج التعرف على الوجه يتشاركون
جينات اكثر بكثير من الاشخاص الاخرين
الذين اعتبرهم البرنامج اقل تشابها سؤال
هنا اذا كان لديك شبيه
يا راويه وحتى سؤال لكم انتم هل سترغبون
في مقابلته تشوفون هذا الشبيه انا بحب
اشوفه
مشاهدينا رؤيه الشبيه وانت ايضا يا عادل
كان نذير شؤم وفقا للفلكلور الانجليزي
والالماني فان هذا يعني ان الموت سيتبعها
كما ان هناك سلسله من القصص الاخباريه حول
الاشخاص الذين يتعقبون اشباههم بنيه سيئه
نتعرف على بعضها مع الزميله لميس
يعني بعد ما تسمعوا هالقصص راح يبطل بدكم
تتعرفوا على ممكن اغير رايي
بعض الاشخاص لم يجلب لهم اشباههم سوى
المتاعب وهذه قصصهم
مثلا قصه العثور على جثه امراه شابه في
اغسطس الماضي في سياره متوقفه في المانيا
تعرفت عليها عائلتها على انها العراقيه
شربانكي البالغه من العمر 23 عاما ولكن مع
التشريح الجثه تبين ان الضحيه هي خديجه
مدونه جزائريه تواصلت معها شربان وقتلتها
للتظاهر بالموت ثم جاء حكم على الروسيا
فيكتوريا البالغه من العمر 47 عاما بالسجن
لمده 21 عاما لسرقه هويه شبيهتها
الامريكيه اولغا بما في ذلك جواز السفر
بعد ان سممتها في منزلها
كما ادين رجل يدعى
وقضى 17 عاما في السجن بالفعل ولكن بعد ان
عرض على شهود جنبا الى جنب مع مشتبها به
اخر لم يتمكن الشهود من التفريق بينهما
فالغى القاضي ادانته
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو الاستاذ المساعد
بكليه العلوم في جامعه الشارقه تخصص علم
الجينات والتطور الدكتور عبد الله المطيري
حياك الله دكتور سعد المباركه صبحك الله
بالخير
خلينا اسالك ذكور بدايه انه انا واحد من
الناس عندي فضول اني اشوف 39 او الاربعين
اللي شابوهن يشابهوني مثل ما يقولون يخلق
من الشبه 40 لكن من يشبهك شكلا هل
بالضروره انه يكون
شبيهك جينيا نفس الجينات عندنا ولا لا
والله بصراحه التشابه ما بين البشر نسبه
99% وشوي اكثر يعني
التشابه البشر مع الفار الله يكرمك تقريبا
98% لكن في عوامل اخرى غير الجينات
تحدد البروفولوجي او الشكل الخارجي اي شخص
من هالبيئه منها شيء يسمونه منها
طريقه التعبير الورادي فيخ حتى لو كان
عندهم نفس الجيل لكن نسبه التشابه يعني مش
بالشكل الخارجي نقدر نقول بالقياسات اللي
يعتمدون العلماء ممكن توصل الى واحد من
واحد يعني ما بينه وانت وانت من واحد 135
يعني انت الان تقدر تقول بوينت زيرو 5 على
مستوى سبعه مليار نسمه
انك تقدر تشوف الشبك
هم موجودين موجودين بس انك
صادفه يعني اقل من زيرو زيرو 5
فهذا هو بنفس كراتنا الارضيه فما بالك زي
ما كان يقال بانه في اخرين طيب دكتور
معروف بانه موضوع الجينات وما يخرج يعني
جمع هذه الجينات بسيك وانس او بترتيب معين
يخرج مليون نتيجه مختلفه لدرجه انه حتى
الاشقاء اللي بيتشاركوا على الاقل 50% من
جيناتهم وحاملين نفس الجينات هاي الجينات
يظهر بطرق مختلفه على حسب ترتيبها مثلا
لون العيون يدخل في 16 جين بحسب علمي حتى
يحدد هذا اللون طيب فكيف كيف يعني انه
احنا نتشارك لهذه الدرجه مع اشخاص لا
يقربون لا نحمل نفس الدم ولا نحمل نفس
الجينات ولكن يشبهون شكلا الى هذه الى هذه
الدرجه
من بدايه الخليقه الى الان هي الجينات
محصوره على 32,000 جنيه
خلال يصير او خلال تطور انه في جينات تظهر
وبعد اجيال تختفي وبعده اجيال اخرى تظهر
ثاني مره فمن ذلك هذا اللي يسمونها الطفره
الجينيه اللي تظهر بين فتره وثانيه ولا لا
تغيير بيجيني يعني احنا متغيره يعني
ابائنا قبل اكثر من 200 سنه ما يحملون
بالضبط نفس الجينات اللي عندنا
اضف الى ذلك ان في عوامل اخرى غير يعني
ممكن انا احمل الجنود انك نفس الجن لكن
اكسبريشن او التعبير الوراث يختلف من عندي
هيك بطريقه مختلفه بالضبط يعني ممكن اثنين
يحملون نفس الجيم مثل ما ذكرتي
في بعض العوامل لها اكثر من جيني مثلا
تتحكم في اكثر من سبع جينات مثلا لون
البشره جينين مسؤولين عنه واحد معناها
تكون نفس طيب هذا يدفع العلم الى تطور
بانه يمكن بعض الامراض التي تصيب شخص من
الممكن ان من خلال العثور على شبيه الجيني
او حتى
الظهور الجين هذه على الشكل وشبيهي من
الممكن ان نستفيد منه
كخلاياك
تصحيح لامراض انا اعاني منها مثلا صحيح
ممكن التشابه الشكلي ممكن يؤدي الى
التشابه الجيني فبالتالي مثل نقل الاعضاء
مثلا
في حاجه اسمها
الخليه فاذا كان في تشابه جدا جدا كبير
يعني ممكن
يطابقون
الكبد ولا ولا
على مستوى طيب دكتور هذا سؤال فضولي هيك
ذكرت في بدايه حديثك بانه حتى نحن كفصيله
البشر نتشارك مع فصائل اخرى من المخلوقات
منها الفئران بنسبه كبيره من الجينات
وعشان هيك بستخدموها للبحث العلمي اجراء
تجارب عليها لانها تشبهنا طيب هل هذا يمكن
ان يفسر ليش في يعني تقريبا كل البشر
بيشبهوا نوع معين يا من الحيوانات يا من
الطيور يا من المخلوقات الاخرى هل هذا هو
التفسير هو التشابه انه الخالق واحد
والجينات واحده الموجوده بالانسان الحيوان
هي نفسها لكن
اريد اقرب اقرب
شكل مختلف تماما عنه لكن بالرغم جينيا
معروف انه اكثر من 98% نسبه تشابه لكن في
اشياء ثانيه اللي هي تعطي المورفولوجي
يعني انا احمل الجين وانت تحمل الجين ممكن
انت يعطيك شكل اخر يعطيك شكل اخر حسب
ترتيب الجينات
طريقه نشره هذه الجينات الموجوده عند
المايس مش
هذا ما ادري احنا خلصنا ولا من
شكرا جزيلا الاسئله كثيره
يعني احنا نتمنى يعني لمينا بكل تفاصيلها
شكرا اللي الاستاذه المساعد بكليه العلوم
في جامعه شرق التخصص علم الجينات والتطور
الدكتور عبد الله المطيري قواك الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات